[Music]
it was all a lie you've never worked for
anything
it was an act breakout role for you here
what has this role meant to you
everything I think playing David has
been a particular treat obviously it's
incredibly tragic but the material for
an actor was just second to none I'm
just so grateful to be a part of it you
know we are at a for your consideration
event
what would a nomination our award for
this role mean to you you know that's a
tricky question for me I'm I look I'm
really happy to be here I'm just gonna
leave that up to the powers that be
there's some phenomenal people in this
show and I'm just glad to run with them
you know well next up for you another
show with some phenomenal people you're
headed to a sacar that's right what can
you tease me with haha I can't tease you
with anything only because it's so under
wraps and it's even under wraps from the
cast we find out right before we're
shooting what's happening so everything
is a surprise and it's every moment in
house of cards as a new I will tell you
that I I work with everybody in the show
so my character gets to do a lot of
backflips and you're not necessarily a
good guy on this show right no one's a
good guy on this show no one that's what
I can tell you but stepping in that's a
show that's been kind of a machine
running and it's gonna have a new energy
for this last season in Saudi energy
we're just getting started
listen everyone is just so thrilled to
be supporting rubber and I think that
she is a powerhouse and it's been about
Robin since season two and anyone who's
in denial of that hasn't been watching
the show so we're just thrilled to get
behind Robin and
she is a powerhouse I mean what she is
doing with Claire underwood is
phenomenal and it's only going to get
more interesting so yeah
[Applause]
[Music]